In the United States,
we have about 330 million people.
And because of the distribution,
relatively normal
distribution of Iq scores,
about 16% have iqs of 85 or two means
they're not going to graduate school.
No,
it means that from,
from what I've read practically,
it means the wonderlic company
has actually done a really,
they have a nice I cute tennis
from the commercial perspective,
you know,
it's actually psychometrically valid
and they've linked Iq levels to,
uh,
to job specifically the job categories,
you know?
No,
not a lot.
I was going to say is they're not
only not going to graduate school,
they're not going to find a stable
job that pays a livable wage.
Yeah.
Now,
especially even given that so many of
the service jobs now require a fair high
degree of computational
savvy or leader built,
no,
not computation,
but ability to interact with complex
computational technology loves the typical
till Latta and a checkout market or the
till at a Mcdonald's because Mcdonald's
is actually very complicated,
is often far beyond the ability of
people who are on the low end of the
intelligence distribution.
And they claimed,
I think it was wonderlic,
although it might know,
it might've been,
it might've been hunt.
What's his name?
Uh,
Iq researcher.
He said Earl haunt,
I think possibly what he claimed that
that if you have an Iq of below 90,
that it's,
it's difficult.
It's difficult for you to read well enough
to translate what you're reading into
action.
So you can't actually read
instructions and follow them.
You don't have that level of literacy.
That's correct.
Yeah.
I was going to say that in,
in the United States,
this bottom 16% translates
into 51 million people.
Right.
Including 13 million
children who are in school.
Right.
This is a very difficult problem.
You know,
I knew where Ohio,
he passed away when I
knew him pretty well.
He also would say that there is this
a cognitive segregation in society.
This is a point that Charles Murray makes.
Yeah.
Well,
and Earl would often ask,
uh,
you know,
when's the last time you had someone
over for dinner who wasn't a college
graduate?
Well,
that was something that Marie and her
Bernstein wrote about in their book the
bell curve,
which really struck me because
I read that book twice,
unlike most of the people criticized it.
And you know,
we're one of the things that
they pointed out in there,
it was,
look,
the,
the typical,
the typical educated person thinks that
someone isn't very bright if they have
an Iq of 150 grand.
How'd you at graduate level,
Phd level research
institutions cause 115 there's,
there's as many people at 115
above as there are at 85 and below.
And so it's a minority of the population
and that's the top 15% and you know,
that's,
that's the dollar undergraduate,
right?
So why don't you just,
people have to see,
I'm a clinical psychologist
and I've dealt with people who,
how do I ranges in the low eighties and
tried to find them jobs and tried to
train them.
And I have some real knowledge about the
stunning gap between people at the low
end of the EICU distribution
and the high end.
And it's,
it's no bloody wonder.
People hate Iq research and intelligence
research because it reveals a set of
seriously,
uh,
dismal facts about the incredible
range of ability among human beings.
Yes.
Um,
this is true.
And Moreover,
I would add to this that
people in universities,
professors and couple
of graduate students,
uh,
have a hard time understanding what the,
what everyday life is.
Like.
If you have an Iq of 85
and we're making your way,
you're living independently,
you were making your way in the world,
but it is a challenge.
It is a really,
I mean,
uh,
just,
just barely begins to describe it.
I had a,
I had a client who he probably had an Iq
of under 80 and nonverbal portion of it
anyways.
And,
um,
he was indistinguishable in
physical appearance from,
from let's say,
I hate to use the frame normal person,
but there's nothing mark
that mark Timm out about,
particularly intellectually impaired,
you know,
and,
uh,
I tried at one point,
this is this,
this was so,
so telling to me.
I got him an inch,
a volunteer job,
which by the way,
it's very difficult.
It's harder to get a volunteer job in a
real job because you have to do police
screening and all sorts of things.
And the selection process
is just as extreme.
But I eventually ended up getting
him a job at a bike store,
bike,
slash,
bookstore and at that place couldn't
hold him once the subsidy program had
expired.
And then I got him a job at a charity and
his job was to fold letters into three
so that they can be put into envelopes.
Well that sounds easy except that he
also had a bit of a motor tremor and you
know,
it took me about 30 hours to train
him to fold up a piece of paper with
sufficient precision so that it can be
put in an envelope rapidly so that the
envelope wasn't so mangled that it
would get stuck in the automatic sorting
machine.
And another is high
performance demands on him too.
He had to whip through those letters
pretty quickly and then sometimes the
letters would have a photograph appended
to them that was stapled on and they
weren't always stapled
on in the same place.
So then he had to calculate how to fold
the paper over the photograph without
bending the photograph in precise third
so that would still fit in the envelope.
And then he had to separate the French
letters from the English letters and
associate them with the proper envelopes
and like that level of complexity just
did him in.
Let me say two things about this.
One is I hope common sense and the other
is pretty provocative but common sense
things.
We had to be very careful when we have
these discussions not to devalue the
human dignity of people who aren't
in the upper end of the distribution.
And if there's one criticism that I
think is fair as sometimes in these
conversations,
it sounds like we're devaluing people at
the lower end and the distribution and
we have to be very careful
that we don't do that.
A human life has dignity and Iq was not
the most important thing that defines
human gifts and beams.
EAGAN,
it's
not associated with wisdom.
It's not necessarily associated with
truth or with courage or with many virtues
that
you like it at all with being
likable there or on time.
How many of all,
we know the psychometric test,
the psychometric relationship between
intelligence and conscientiousness is
zero.
Right?
We have to make that point.
Yes,
I agree.
I'm trying to make the point about how
difficult it is for people who are on the
low end of the cognitive
spectrum to survive in a,
in an increasingly complex,
cognitively sophisticated environment.
Right.
Your obs are just disappearing.